The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILL MA: So today
I promised I would
play through the second
half of the tournament
that I started last
time, so two times ago,
but before Jennifer
Shahade's guest lecture.
But before I start,
so remember last time
we got to the final table.
This is essentially the
start of the final table.
And but before I
get into the hands,
I want to do a bit of
theory first that I've been
forgoing so far in this class.
And it's essentially what's
called the independent chip
mode, or ICM theory.
And essentially what it's
used for is in tournaments,
essentially the value of
chips is essentially nonlinear
because you're not really trying
to just get all the chips.
You are trying to last
as long as possible
and move up the payouts.
So I want to now formally
quantify what this means
and how you calculate the
EV of your game rules.
So far I think
I've just told you
everything that's done so far
in this class has been chip EV.
And I've told you just
play to maximize chip EV.
Maximize your expected
number of chips.
And that's a pretty
reasonable way to play.
In cash games, it's
what you want to do.
And in tournaments it's
not a bad approximation.
So I don't want everyone
after this ICM lecture
to think, you know, I've
got to completely change
my playing in tournaments
because that's not the case.
Essentially, playing
and maximizing
expected number of chips is
a pretty good approximation
of how you actually
should be playing.
But there are some
small differences
in extreme situations,
and I'd like
to highlight some of that today.
So OK, yeah.
So this is essentially-- so it's
this idea of minimizing risk
to stay alive and move up
to the escalating payouts.
So I want to make an
important distinction, though.
When I'm saying,
we're still trying
to maximize our expected
amount of money.
What I'm saying, you should
be minimizing your risk
in a tournament so that you
can move up the payouts.
That's different than
saying you should minimize
your monetary risk
because I'm still
assuming we're trying to
maximize our expected money
without worrying about risk.
But we're only minimizing
tournament risk
to maximize your
expected amount of money.
But I'm not saying
we should be overly
conservative in a
tournament and just
trying to move up the
money ladder slowly
when you should be gambling
because it's positive money
expectation.
If you find yourself
in this situation,
then if you're trying to
play professionally and just
maximize your expected amount
of money in every situation,
then you should probably
play smaller tournaments,
where this is not
really the case--
where this doesn't
occur too often.
I can understand in practice,
if you play poker for fun
and you made it
far in a tournament
and it's the top,
let's say, 50K,
and there's 55 left, I can
understand why you might not
want to make a positive money
expectation play because you've
played this tournament.
You're probably not going
to be in the situation
that many times
in your lifetime.
And you just really
want to cash the World
Series of Poker main
event or something.
And I think that's a
reasonable life decision.
I'm not criticizing
that life decision.
But I'm going to talk about
all of these decisions
assuming we don't
care about that.
We're still trying to maximize
expected amount of money.
And if you are playing
professionally,
where you're getting into that
situation very frequently,
then it is very important to
maximize risk in some cases
and to maximize your dollar EV
because in tournaments, you're
losing most of the time.
You really have to win a lot
the times that you do win.
You can't be content
because we made $30,000
if we could have made $50,000.
So OK.
So what is the exact formula
for ICM/ So I'm just going
to demonstrate how to
calculate the value of chips
in a tournament with an example.
So ICM is essentially
a formula to calculate
how much your stack is
worth in a tournament.
So let's suppose there's
three players left
and that payouts are 5, 3, 2.
This is a common
structure in sit-and-goes
if you've played those, which
are 10-player tournaments.
So this is the
statement is essentially
your chances of winning
the tournament is
proportional to your
percent of the total chips.
And essentially we're
assuming this is true,
and we're going to derive
from it all the formulas.
And this statement is
approximately true.
There are more advanced
ICM calculators
that also take into
account your position
if the stack sizes are rather
shallow because there are
some inaccuracies
because this statement,
it calculates only
based on chips.
But if you're folding
and then you're
the button the next hand,
which is the best position,
then that's actually
an entire big blind
better almost than being
under the gun the next hand.
But we're not going
to worry about that.
We're just going to
assume your chances
of winning the tournament is
proportional to your percentage
of chips.
So how do we calculate this?
So you can't really do
it by hand in practice.
But for this example
with three people,
I'll show you how
to do it by hand.
So let's suppose the chips
stacks are also 5, 3, 2.
OK, so the payouts are 5, 3, 2.
And the chip stacks
are also 5, 3, 2 ratio.
If chip EV equals money EV,
then the guy with 5,000,
their equity from the
tournament should be $5.
And the guy in third
place, their equity
should be $2, right?
But this is clearly not correct
because the guy in third place
is guaranteed $2.
And clearly there's
a nonzero chance
of them winning the tournament.
So clearly their equity
is actually more than $2.
And then similarly
if you're player A,
your equity is clearly not $5
because you're not guaranteed
to win the tournament.
So it's clear from this
example why if you just do chip
EV equals money EV,
that's clearly wrong.
Is that clear to everyone?
So how do we calculate it?
So let's calculate
it for player C.
So essentially what it's
saying, your chances
of winning, your
chances of coming first
is 2,000 over
10,000, which is 20%.
And then to calculate your
chances of coming second,
you just condition on each
of the other player's way.
So conditioned on
A winning, which
would happen 50% of
the time, we assume
that our chances
of coming second
is 2,000 divided by 5,000,
which is the remaining
number of chips besides player
A. Does that make sense?
So player A has 5,000 chips.
So between you who's
player C and player D,
there's 5,000 chips in total,
and you got 2,000 of those.
So it's 2,000 over
5,000, so it's 0.4.
And then if player B wins, then
your chances of coming second
is 2,000 over 7,000.
So overall, your chances
of coming second is 0.4--
So it says, 50% times
0.4 plus 30% times 2/7,
which equals 2/7.
So then you can
calculate your equity
is-- you're guaranteed $2.
And you have a 20% chance of
winning, which would give you
three additional dollars.
And then a 29% chance of coming
second, which would give you
an additional dollar.
So your equity is actually
2.89 in this case.
is actually closer to second
place than third place.
Does that calculation
make sense to everyone?
So if there's five
players, you just
have to recursively condition.
You have to condition on
player A winning and then
go through all the possibilities
of who can come second.
Then go through all
the possibilities
of who could comes third,
et cetera, et cetera.
So it's not a calculation you
can really do in your head.
But that it's quite easy to find
a calculator to do it for you.
You just Google ICM calculator,
and you punch it in.
And even though it's not--
it grows exponentially.
But there's only going
to be nine players.
So it's still fine.
It won't take that--
the computer can
do it instantly,
even for 9-10 players.
OK, so what are some cases
where ICM is easy to calculate?
So like I said, in cash games,
there is no such thing as ICM.
You're just playing to maximize
expected number of chips.
And your goal is
essentially, you're
sitting out at the cash game
looking to get into all-ins,
looking to get into
favorable all-ins,
hopefully winning the person
who you're targeting's money.
And in winner-takes-all
tournaments,
it's also the same
because you're just
looking at your chances
of winning the tournament.
And that's always just
your number of chips.
So you're just
trying to maximize
expected number of chips.
So as a corollary, once it
gets down to two players,
there's no more
such thing as ICM.
Three is the minimum
number of players you
need for ICM to be relevant.
Once it's two players, it's
just maximize your chip EV
because there's no sense of
trying to survive in hopes
that someone else busts first.
Because with only two people,
for the other guy to bust,
you have to take
all their chips.
OK, so what are some
mathematical corollaries
of ICM formula?
So big stacks have money
EV less than chip EV.
Small stacks have money
EV greater than chip EV.
Small stacks also tend to have
positive chip EV in general.
This is something I didn't
mention to you much.
But in general-- so you
might have seen this
if you guys have been to a
casino and played cash games.
So let's say you sit down
at a table in a cash game
and everyone buys in
for 100 big blinds.
At some tables, usually
they'll allow you to buy in
for as low as 20 big blinds.
And if you do this,
in general, that's
going to be positive EV for
the guy with 20 big blinds
because there's situations
where they have to--
Where, let's say, they have
to essentially sometimes
one guy will raise.
One guy will call.
And then you can go all in.
And one guy will go
all in on top of you.
And the other guy will fold.
And then you have dead money.
So another thing is early
on in the tournament,
ICM is irrelevant.
You just want to
accumulate chips.
So if you try to do this formula
early on in a tournament, what
you'll find is
essentially you're
so far away from the money
that none of the things
really matter to maximize
your chances of even
getting to the money.
You just want to maximize
your number of chips.
So where is ICM most relevant?
It's most relevant on
the exact payout bubble
and on the final table.
So roughly speaking, in
every poker tournament
I've seen other than strange
ones that are winner-takes-all
or satellites, the payout
looks roughly like this.
So it's 0.
You go in, and once you hit
about top 20% is the bubble.
And then there's a jump here
where suddenly you get paid.
This is about 80% get 0.
So here there's a
jump, and then it
escalates slowly until you
get to the final table.
Final-- sorry, I'll
actually switched to color--
final table.
And then it escalates
really fast.
So essentially basically ICM
is most relevant at the points
where essentially,
the derivative,
or the rate of change
the payout, is highest.
And those points, as you
can see, are here and here.
So essentially it matters
most at the exact money bubble
and in the final table.
OK, let me clear this.
OK, so yeah, so
some more extreme
examples of ICM
you have one chip
left late in the tournament
when everyone else
has thousands of chips.
So clearly this ship
is worth a lot more
than its value as a
fraction of the chips.
And you're just trying to
survive with this one chip
essentially instead of
trying to win more chips.
Maybe I'll calculate
this in a bit.
So in satellites--
what satellites are
are there are
tournaments where you're
trying to qualify for
a bigger tournament.
So essentially the
important thing
is there will be
maybe 100 players.
And there will be
10 seats, which
means the top 10 get an invite
to the bigger tournament.
And then everyone
else gets nothing.
So I guess the qualifiers for
the MIT Series of Poker Main
Event are kind of like this.
I guess there's
other prizes, to.
But you're essentially
trying to come top 10.
So this is how that works.
And in that case, the
payout is essentially this.
So there's not really
much incentive to win.
You're just trying to be one
of this top 10% that gets paid.
So that's another case where
ICM has extreme importance.
And you often find--
well, not often--
but you can often
make a case for folding
pocket aces preflop
even though you know it's
going to have positive chip
EV if you call because it's
the best possible hand.
But because you just really
don't want to bust, then
just you want to fold aces.
OK, we'll talk about
this a bit more later.
OK, so let's get back
to the tournament.
So this is the final table.
So ICM is going to be
quite relevant here.
As I'm talking through my
decisions in the hands,
I'll talk about the
ICM decisions as well.
This is the first hand, or I
think maybe one orbit passed.
We're at the final table.
We're the second biggest stack.
We should maybe look
at the stack sizes.
So we look around
So what do you notice
about the stack sizes?
Or specifically,
how are we doing?
How many chips do we have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILL MA: Real.
Right.
We have quite a lot, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILL MA: We have quite a lot,
but we're not in first place.
There's this one
guy who covers us.
So this Panpancrisy
So specifically, the
thing I'm trying to avoid
is getting in a big
pot with Panpancrisy.
Let's say he goes all in,
and I have pocket kings.
I'm going to call.
But I'm not going to be
that happy about calling
in a situation where otherwise
I should be very unhappy.
Just because chances are
he's going to have an ace.
He's going to have 30% equity.
It's still going to be
positive money EV call,
but it's so bad if I basically
bust right now in eighth place
against Panpancrisy.
So essentially I'm
really incentivized
to avoid getting in
big pots with him.
And I'm essentially hoping for
some of these smaller stacks
to bust so that then, even
if I lose a big pot to him,
I don't get the low
eighth place payout.
So OK, so it's folded of us.
We raise here.
I think this is one
of the weakest hands I
am raising from the button.
But so far players have
seemed to be reasonably tight,
so I'm going to raise.
And then I get the blinds.
OK, so I'll skip some
hands at the beginning.
Near the end, I'll
play every hand.
This hand we don't play, but
I'll try to show the hands
were someone busts.
So this hand small
blind goes all in.
Big blind calls.
And so small blind
wins with 10-2
suited against ace-4, which is
basically great for everyone
at the table.
Because someone
busted, you're always
cheering for people
who bust essentially.
And I think also both
of their plays are fine.
So I think small blinds
play-- it looks a bit silly.
But realistically not only does
10-2 suited have reasonable
equity when you're
called, it's also--
the ICM is very, very relevant.
This Gerardocks guy,
he's not the shortest.
He is one of the shortest, so
he does need to take some risk,
but he's still really
very much would like
to bust after I show to Heap78.
So he can't call with anything.
With ace-4, I think that's
definitely good enough to call.
But let's say they
have king-2 offsuit.
I think that's the situation
I'd normally call if it was not
a final table in a tournament.
But at the final table,
where I'm not the shortest
and there's someone
shorter than me,
I would consider folding 10-2--
sorry, king-2 offsuit here just
because of ICM essentially.
All right, so the next hand--
so the big blind busts.
And then there's no
small blind in this hand,
which is great because people
are less incentivized to steal.
And indeed we get
our big blind back.
AUDIENCE: That works.
WILL MA: Very nice.
OK, so not much happens here.
I'll skip forward a bit.
OK, this hand--
I guess it's quite
convenient for us.
But this still
illustrates a point.
So this guy, who
dealt a bit earlier,
now he goes all in
for quite a lot.
This is quite a big shove.
And if you play by
my recommendations,
I would never recommend
shoving this many bets.
It's 24.
That's quite a lot--
actually, 23, sorry.
It's 23 big blinds, which
is way too much to shove.
There's no need
to risk this much.
But once again, I think his play
is justifiable because of ICM.
So let's see what he had.
So we call.
Here it's a bit
different because even
if I call and lose, I'm
not out of the tournament.
Even if I would be out,
even if he had 200,000,
I'd probably still
call with queens.
It's just too good to fold.
So we need ace-queen here,
which is great for us.
But if you look at the play
from his perspective again,
it actually seems
quite reasonable
if you think about it
because for him, ace-queen
is a great hand
from this position.
It's definitely
good enough where
if it was between folding and
shoving for 23 big blinds,
you would definitely rather
shove for 23 big blinds.
So the main reason why normally
one would criticize his play
is because why doesn't he just
raise small with ace-queen?
Well, understandably,
he doesn't really
want to incentivize me
to reraise or Panpancrisy
to make a reraise.
He essentially wants
to minimize the chances
that he has to play for
his stack in this hand.
And the way he does that is
essentially by going all in.
Looking at back at it, I
think his play is fine.
The only weakness of
his play, I think,
is it is a bit predictable what
his hand is in this situation
because I think if he had a
hand as good as pocket aces,
then he shouldn't be doing this.
He should just be raising
small because it's good enough
where he's happy getting it
in against me or Panpancrisy.
Whereas also if his
hand was slightly worse,
like ace-jack offsuit I
think is a good example,
I think ace-jack offsuit
is not strong enough
to make this all-in play with.
But you still want
to be raising.
So I think there's a
small range of hands
that you want to be making
this all-in play is.
I think it's basically
exactly he's queen offsuit,
may ace-king, maybe
ace-queen, ace-king.
And then middle pairs, let's
say between like pocket 8s
and pocket 10s or something.
So the only downside
of this play I think
is essentially his range
here is very predictable it's
going to be ace-jack suited
plus ace-queen and pocket 8s
through 10s or
something like that.
But nonetheless, I think,
because it's a final table,
because of ICM, it's fine.
He gets unlucky, though.
He runs into queens.
All right, here
we've got to walk.
OK, so let's see this hand.
So I showed to--
raises goes all in.
So we call here.
We're deep enough where I want
to give myself the opportunity
to fold if Panpancrisy
he goes all-in.
And we call.
And we win.
So OK, so I guess
I've been running
pretty good in this tournament.
But I just want to
point out, there
is a lot of selection
bias here because I'm not
going to play
through a tournament
where I get all-in on
the first hand and lose.
So I mean I'm going to pick a
tournament that I [INAUDIBLE]..
So it's in some sense not
the best pedagogical example
because there is a
lot of selection bias.
You know that I'm going to run
very good in the tournament I
choose to show you guys.
But if it's between that
and having be over in
five minutes because I lost--
[LAUGHTER]
--this is the
lesser of two evils.
All right, so here, yeah.
So once again, this is a
pretty-- it's not that big,
but it's a 17 big blind shove.
And once again, it's
justified by ICM prefold.
OK, here, queen-7 off.
Yeah, I shove.
I think it's probably barely a--
I think it's pretty close
if chip EV equals money EV.
It would be a borderline
shove with the smallish antes.
But given ICM, I know he's
less incentivized to call
than usual.
So all borderline hands I'm
going to be shoving, so I do.
OK, so this hand we get king-10.
So once again, I just shove.
Once again, I think I--
basically it's hard for
them to call if I just shove
and because of ICM.
So I'm essentially
bullying him, bully them.
So when you're
the big stack, you
can bully people at the
final table because of ICM.
We do get lucked
up here, though.
And we get lucked up at ace-8.
And so he wins.
I'm not going to do
an exact calculation
because I'm going to do an
exact ICM calculation later.
I would guess his call
is very borderline.
It's definitely positive
chip expectancy,
but the fact that there's
this guy with only 57,000
and this guy with 70,000,
I think it's a call.
But I think ace-6 is
definitely a fold.
So I think it's probably
one of the weakest hands he
should be calling with.
I think ace-8 is
probably too good.
He has to call, but I think it's
very borderline in either case
because of ICM.
So he does fold, though.
So now ICM is a bit trickier
because now we're smaller.
We're getting it all in with
any of these guys can really
damage us.
And there's still
two short stacks
that everyone is
hoping will bust soon.
So In this situation, I
could go all in and bully
this Panpancrisy guy, but
ICM isn't that relevant.
He's not going to fold
ace-queen if I go all in.
So I just give this one to him.
Calling is probably bad
anyway, but calling, I think,
is especially bad
because it just
increases the chances of
getting in a bigger pot.
OK, we'll skip forward a bit.
Let's see this hand.
So ace-10 off here.
So this guy makes it 12,000.
And I guess I've skipped
a bunch of hands.
So Nicholas Brody, I think,
has been very active.
And overall, I think people
have become very active.
Everyone's playing
a lot of pots.
So overall, I am going to
put people on wider ranges
than I normally do.
But nonetheless here,
I still fold ace-10.
I think it's ace-jack I
would probably get it in.
And ace-10 suited, I
think I'd get it in.
Ace-10 suited is borderline.
Once again, when you're tied
between getting in a smaller
pot and getting in a bigger
pot, you want to be folding.
Yeah, so I guess
at a final table,
I should make this clear.
It's not like you
want to fold more.
It's you want to go all in
more when you're first to act.
But call other
people's all-ins less.
So that's exactly
what's going on here.
He's already moved all in.
And I'm going to
fold to his all-in
more often than
in a normal game.
But as you can see,
I haven't really
been tighter in every sense
because when I get to go first,
I think actually going all
in more often and risking it
more often because I
know my opponents are
highly incentivized to fold.
So they go all in.
I fold here.
So Nicholas Brody also
folds, which I guess is fine.
Definitely he had pretty
odds he called there.
But once again, ICM just makes--
it changes things up a bit.
Jack-7 suited, once again,
is a pretty big shove,
but jack-7 suited plenty
good [INAUDIBLE]----
ICM relevant.
Pocket 9s here.
We make it 12,000 on the button.
So here I think pocket
9s is good enough
where I'm happy if one of them
reraises all-in, and I call.
So essentially my
strategy here is
I'm going to shove all
my medium strength hands
and especially hands
that don't play
well postflop ace-2 offsuit.
And then I'm going to raise
small with some of my hands
that are less good preflop but
better postflop, let's say,
10-8 suited, and also my
monster hands like pocket nines
that are also reasonable
to play postflop.
So Nicholas Brody calls here.
And the flop is ace,
jack, 7 with the hearts.
So it's a bad flop
for our hand, but it's
a good flop for
our range because I
think, given the way the table
was going, I was opening a lot.
And Nicholas Brody
is very aggressive.
I would guess unless
he had like pocket
aces, which he might slow
play, he would reraise most.
I wasn't 100% sure-confident,
but I was reasonable--
I'd say maybe 85% confident
that if he had an ace preflop,
he would have just
went all in preflop.
So overall, I'd still say it's
a very good flop for my range
because I think he's way less
likely to have an ace than me.
There's a small
chance maybe he would
chicken out with ace-2
offsuit and just call.
But given how
aggressive he's been,
I would be surprised
if he did that.
So I decided to bet here.
And I'm still not sure
how good this bet is.
So I think at the
time I bet, because
of my logic that it's really
hard for him to have an ace,
and so I think the best
strategy for me on this flop
and in this situation is to
just bet 100% of my hands.
And he's just forced
to fold basically
very often because he can't
really keep up with an ace.
I can just continue betting.
That being said,
though, I do think
if I do decide as
part of my strategy
to check any part
of my range here,
pocket 9s might actually be
one of the best possible hands
to check back.
So I think checking back
would have been fine.
I guess I'd bet here
because I told myself,
I want my strategy to be bet
100% of my hands, which I did.
And he folds, which is
reasonably smart because he
knows that I can bet again.
And he's going to have to make
a decision for all his chips
probably.
And it's just going to be tough.
OK, this hand--
BeMySponsor goes all
in, gets [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why would you say,
pocket 9s is one of the best
hands to check back here?
WILL MA: I very rarely
get called by worse,
and I get called by
everything better.
I think he's always calling a
jack and usually folding a 7.
Maybe he won't fold 7-8
with some back door draws,
but I think he'll
usually call a jack.
And maybe he'll
call a 7 sometimes.
But I still think mostly
it's just he'll basically
fold everything that beats
me and call everything that--
sorry, he'll fold everything
that I beat and call everything
that beats me basically.
Yeah, but I still decide
to bet, nonetheless, just
to win the pot there
and not give him
extra outs if he happens to
have 10-6 suited or something.
So OK, so we'll go
through this hand.
So Panpancrisy raises.
He doesn't go all
in, which is curious.
But LPMBox calls.
He calls again.
It's checked.
And then LPMBox goes on
in the river [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, jack-7 here?
Yes.
I guess, so once again,
Nicholas Brady raises.
And then LPMBox goes on
over him, wins a big pot.
So I guess I do the
same for Nicholas Brady.
He's been raising a lot,
so pockets 6s good enough
to risk going all in there.
OK, this hand-- so we
get ace-jack suited.
And I raise from cutoff.
So I've been raising
to a fairly small size
because the antes are smaller.
So that's one thing to
remember at a final table is
the pots are actually a bit
smaller because with only five
players the ante, the sum of
the antes, instead of normally
the 6,000, is only
3,000 in this case.
So the big blind has
worse odds to call.
So Nicholas Brady goes all in.
I look him up ace-jack suited--
definitely good enough.
Also at this point,
because a number of pots
have gone my way, I'm big enough
where even if I call and lose
this, I won't be chip
leader, but I'll still
have a decent amount of chips.
So unfortunately we
lose the ace-8 here.
So now we're second
place, but we're still
doing reasonably well.
I could just maybe
gone all in here.
I guess this guy
has a lot of chips.
But I could've raised
to a bigger size
to disincentive Nicholas
Brody from doing this
with the right
wide range of hands
and then protecting my stack
more from an ICM point of view.
But I'm happy with--
I think ace-jack suited
is just good enough
where I'm happy
calling his all-in,
which I should have
been in this case.
I guess he had ace-6.
OK, so jack-10 suited here.
So yeah, here I just
decided to fold.
I mean we could consider
doing a crazy bluff all-in,
but I don't think this
guy's folding that often.
They made a rather
big reraise preflop
from going three times
the initial opening.
So Nicholas Brody goes all
in here, and they do fold.
So Nicholas Brody picking
up a bunch of chips.
So he just takes it down again.
He's been raising quite a lot.
Here we get a raise and a call.
So LPMBox has been raising
over other people's--
opens quite a lot.
So he gets called here,
but he holds and wins,
which is definitely
bad news for everyone.
If I could pay 10,000
chips into the pot
to have this all-in
go the other way,
it almost certainly
would be profitable.
The amount actually
we'd be willing to pay
you make this all-in go the
other way is probably 25,000.
It's a ridiculous amount
because just the value
of having people bust
and moving up the payouts
is so significant,
especially when I'm
not such a big stack anymore.
OK, so now this guy,
he just doubled up.
So I guess we were
running pretty good.
But I'd say in the last two or
three orbits, as you can see,
a lot of things haven't
been that favorable.
We've lost some all-ins.
And also people
haven't really busted.
The chips are just being
passed around the table, which
is basically not what
you're hoping for.
So king-10 offsuit.
We get a walk.
So walk just means that
everyone folds to you,
and the big blind.
I think we've actually
gotten quite a lot of walks
at this final table.
So something we can
keep in mind if we're
trying to play exploitatively
later, queen-jack, go all in.
He folds.
So at 8-7 I guess, LPMBox, after
winning that, so as you notice,
the big stacks are the ones
who win most of the pots.
And this is expected.
So whenever ICM is relevant,
you would expect that--
so although the small stacks had
a higher chip EV, then-- sorry,
had a higher money
EV than chip EV,
usually the chips
get transferred
from the small stack
to the big stacks
because the big stacks
have more license
to go all in first and
bully people around.
So he takes this one down.
Next hand, we get jacks here.
So Panpancrisy is
actually short now even
though he started the final
table as the chip leader
because he's lost
a bunch of all-ins.
He gets an all-in here,
and we hold against a 6.
So there's actually an
interesting play here.
I don't think he
should have done it.
But this is actually
often a good ICM play.
So normally I would
say in this situation,
if you have a good hand,
just go all in because he
knows I'm going to call.
So when ace-6, he
just went all in.
But often there's this play
called the stop-and-go, which
is in practice not very good.
I don't think it
would have been here,
but it's an interesting
theoretical concept,
which is instead of going
on, he just calls, OK?
He calls, and then
he basically blindly
goes all in on the flop.
He doesn't actually
have to, but this
is what players used to do.
And you can do
this in live poker.
What you would do
in this situation is
you would say, call, and before
the dealer even deals the flop,
you would just say, all in.
And this is a legal play.
The point is
essentially-- it's an ICM.
The justification, which I
think is mostly wrong but still
interesting, is he
wants to maximize
the chances that I fold.
So essentially, OK, this
is strictly better, right?
Sorry, the fact that he would
call, let me see the flop,
and then I get to decide
whether to put the remaining
chips in sounds like it
should be better for me
than me having to put
all the chips in preflop.
But the main reason
why he does this
is because he wants me to have
an opportunity to fold my cards
and avoid getting in a
situation where both of us
are playing for
our entire stack.
So this is the
justification for it.
So even though you're giving
your opponent more information,
you're also
decreasing the chances
that they decide to
call to the river card
and have more chances
of beating you.
So that justification
is correct,
but it's just that if
you've crunched the numbers,
usually this situation
won't be favorable enough.
And usually you don't want
to be giving your opponent
that extra information.
OK, so finally someone busts.
We get jacks off again.
So here normally I think I would
often consider calling this,
but I think just avoid-- so
now the stacks are even--
we're the chip leader
but not by a ton--
and I don't really want
to get in a big pot here.
So I decide to give it to
them, even though normally I
would definitely call this.
King-7 suited.
I make a pretty big
all-in for 21 and 1/2 bets
from the small blind.
And take it down.
All right, we'll
see all the hands.
We fold 6-3 suited here.
BeMySponsor decided
to raise small, which
is, once again, a bit unusual.
You usually just want to go
all in in a situation where
ICM is so relevant.
And then Nicholas goes all in.
And he folds.
Jack-5 offsuit.
Here we fold.
So once again, this
guy raises small.
So maybe he doesn't really
want to do this ICM thing
and just he wants to play pots.
He takes that one down, though.
Nicholas Brody-- so as you
can see, it's a bit boring.
There's not too many hands here.
That's what happens with there's
ICM because you don't really
want to splash around.
You just want to survive
in the tournament
by risking all your
chips once in a while
instead of slowly bleeding your
chips in a variety of pots.
So once again, queen-9
suited, big all in.
Plenty good enough.
Queen-7 suited, I
decide to raise it up.
But unfortunately, I guess, even
if just one guy went all in,
I'm clearly folding.
So they both go all in.
And ace-king beats kings, which
is really bad news for everyone
essentially because
if kings held,
then he would have busted.
But unfortunately he doesn't.
So pocket 8s, I'm raising here.
This would have been a
gross spot, by the way.
I think if BeMySponsor
went on here,
I don't know what
it would have done.
it would have been very
gross because on one hand,
I definitely don't want to
be folding a hand as good
as pocket 8s.
But on the other hand,
ICM is just so relevant,
I think I probably have to fold.
So yeah, this is a case where
I could've made an extreme,
a hero fold essentially.
I folded a very good hand
if BeMySponsor went all in.
So king-jack off--
you get another walk.
OK, jack-10 off.
I'll tell you what happened,
and then we'll take a break.
And then I'll analyze it after.
This hand I want to
analyze in a bit more depth
because I was actually
surprised going
through the replays looking
at how I played this.
So LPMBox makes it 16,000.
And I reraise to 44,444, so
essentially I think this--
I don't have a great hand.
But I think this hand is too
good not to make a bluff with.
So I do that.
And then he goes all in.
And then I think this
is a very tough spot
because my hand isn't good.
But when I reraise, I
definitely had the--
if this guy had
fewer chips, I would
have just went all in myself.
I definitely didn't
reraise to this size
thinking I would even consider
folding if he moved on.
So yeah, the reason
I made this size
is so that if this guy
went all in, I could fold.
But as it turns out, he
folded, and he went all in.
So let's analyze this
hand after the break.
We'll take a short
two-three minute break.
OK, I'll get started again.
So OK, so let's
calculate this hand.
So I actually decided to go
back and calculate this hand
from an ICM perspective because
ICM is basically very relevant
here.
OK, so let's see exactly
how to do this in practice.
OK, so let's first do the
chip EV calculation, OK?
Let me first do the
chip EV calculation.
You can trust that I copied
the numbers correctly.
So essentially there's
three possibilities, OK?
There is if I fold, this
is the amount of chips.
This is the amount
of chips I'll have.
OK, so right now I'm
only caring about chips.
So if I fold, this is the
amount of chips I'll have.
If I call and win, this is
the number of chips I'll have.
And if I call and lose, this is
the amount of chips I'll have.
So we could basically do a
calculation here where I do
essentially it's-- so let's
say my chances of winning is x.
So it's x times how many chips
I have if I call and lose,
which is 107--
I'm going to not write
the last three zeros--
plus 1 minus x times 402.
Sorry, I did this in reverse.
OK, x is my chances of losing.
So again, I'm
basically comparing
this number versus how many
chips I have if I fold, OK?
And then essentially
I'm just solving for x.
So the way I do it is I
set these to be equal,
and then I calculate x.
And that's the
breakeven x, which
tells me what's the minimum
equity I need against his range
to call.
So we can do that.
So I think it turns out to be--
so this formula is equal to
fold minus call over-- hang on--
I did it before.
OK, so this is easy.
OK, so I Ctrl+Z, so essentially
I had 2 to 1 odds, right?
I had 2 to 1 odds,
so it makes sense
that I needed a 33% equity call.
OK, so how do we do this side?
These are essentially
the ICM numbers.
So essentially the
way you calculate
this is you Google
ICM calculator,
and then you just
go to the first one.
It's usually quite easy to find.
OK, so it's a bit
tricky because you have
to put in the exact payouts.
So I think at the
time they were 18.5.
This is all as a percentage
of the total pot.
So I forget exactly the numbers,
but it was something like this.
OK, and then you type
in the four-- you type
in the stack sizes.
So it takes a bit
of time and even
if you're fast at this, if
you conserve your entire time
bank from the whole tournament
for this one calculation,
you'd probably have
enough time to do it
because you'll probably have
like two or three minutes
of time bank saved up.
So you probably can do it.
You have to essentially, right?
So there's three possibilities.
I have to calculate if I fold,
not only how many chips I have
but how many chips
everyone else has.
And then I take them in,
and then I can essentially
calculate the value of my
stack in terms of as a fraction
of the total money in the pot.
And then similarly, I do
it for the other two cases.
And then I calculate
the ICM numbers.
And roughly speaking,
this is my--
this is all normalized.
This is roughly my dollar EV in
each of these three scenarios.
If I do the same
calculation, I'll
find that I actually
need 39.6 equity.
So far does the calculation
make sense to everyone?
I didn't do all the
steps in practice,
but I explained how
to do all the steps.
Yeah, if you're
fast, it still takes
like a minute-a minute and 1/2.
But the last part is now we
have to open Poker [INAUDIBLE]..
And now we have to type
in jack-10 offsuit.
And then we have to
put him on the range.
So OK, let's just put him on a--
OK, I suspect that
I'm probably going
to have to fold because
39.6% is quite a lot.
I'm going to put him on the
loosest range and see a 539.6.
So let's say he's pretty loose.
So he's willing to gamble with,
let's say, pocket 4s plus--
I mean, another
thing that's relevant
here is I think it looks like
he doesn't have fold equity.
I don't think when
he's going all in here
he suspects that
I'm ever folding.
Or at least he
probably thinks I'm
calling him the overwhelming
majority of the time.
So I think he's rarely going to
turn up a stone bluff like 8-7
suited because of this.
I would be very
surprised if he ever
had 8-7 suited unless
he read into this
and realized that I could
actually fold some hands here,
which maybe he did.
I should give him enough credit.
OK, let's just do
something somewhat quick.
Let's say he gets ace-8
offsuit, ace-5 suited
plus, king-jack suited,
king-queen off, and pocket
4s plus.
So that's 14.6% of hands.
So let's do this.
So against this we
have 36% equity.
So that's not enough.
We need 39.
Let's see how wide his range
has to be for us to have 39.
All right, let's say he
gets in with 20% of hands,
which is quite a lot, which
is, I think, way too much.
Let's say 18.6 percent of hands.
Oh, we actually have
worse against this range
because it has-- oops-- because
it has more hands that dominate
us because I put in a
lot of hands like king-10
and removed a lot of
the hands like ace-4.
So basically OK, you can play
with it however you want.
But I think it's hard
to play with it in a way
to give yourself 39%
equity unless you
were very optimistic about
how wide his range was.
So in either case, so
at the time I did fold.
And it looks weird to me at
first, but after analyzing it,
I think this is
definitely the right play
if you take into account ICM.
So I think it's a
good example of ICM
because if you remember when
we were playing with it,
our equity was always
essentially between 33 and 39.
If we put them on a looser
range, our equity would be 37.
And if we put them on a tighter
ranger, our equity would be 34.
But basically it's a
situation where I would always
call if ICM was not
relevant and always fold
if ICM was relevant.
And this isn't even a case
where it looks like ICM
should be that relevant.
Yeah, so we do fold.
So with hindsight, maybe my
initial strategy was wrong.
Maybe I should have should
not have even bluffed here.
Maybe I should have just
folded in the first place.
That's a different story.
But given that I
did bluff, I think
the best thing I
can do here is fold.
OK, let me just jump back
to the PowerPoint for a bit.
So I just want to
talk about a bit more
about this theory of satellites
and going all in first.
So in game theory, this is
called the traffic intersection
game.
So ICM does not
say, play tighter.
It allows you to play looser
if you can go all in first.
So this is where
I actually think
it's very interesting
because in satellites, you
want to be under the gun.
So normally in poker, that's the
worst position because you've
got to act first.
Everyone else gets
to act after you.
But in satellites,
basically you just
want to be the first person to
be able to threaten, say, look,
I'm putting all my chips in.
You pretty much have to fold.
So in satellites, let's
say there's 11 people left,
and 10 people get a seat.
If you go on, no
one can call you
even if they have aces
because to call you,
they essentially need
to be more than 10/11
sure that they're
going to win the hand.
And even if they
have pocket aces,
they're not going to be
10/11 sure that they're
going to win the hand.
So basically going all in
first is very, very good.
So it's called the
traffic interception game
because you can imagine
the situation where
there's two cars trying to pass
each other at an intersection.
And you want to save
time, get there first.
But you're worried that
the other guy might crash.
Both players really
want to avoid disaster,
but both players really
want to be the guy
to get through first.
Well, if you can act first, and
if you just tell the guy, look,
I'm closing my eyes.
I'm tying up my hands.
I cannot stop my car, OK?
I'm just going to go through
the intersection no matter what.
If you're the first person
to be able to do this, then
the other guy, he's
like, OK, I guess
I've got to stop my car
now and let you go first.
That's essentially
what it's like.
If you're the first person to go
all in and you've already said,
look, I'm all in,
and there's nothing
I can do to take my chips back,
then the other guy is like,
all right, I guess I'll follow.
And you can win the blinds.
So it's sort of how it works.
Of course, some opponents
are not rational.
If you do this
enough times, they
might be like, OK, screw this.
I'm just going to kill
this guy and speed up.
So it's a bit weird, and in
practice, this happens a lot,
too.
I've definitely had very
bad situations where
I'm going all in
with any two cards,
and I know this is a game
theoretically optimal strategy.
But my opponents are sped up.
And then he calls me with
ace-jack or something.
And then I'll have
jack-2 offsuited.
And he looks like a
genius, and he beats me
when his play is just
terrible basically.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so interesting.
So does it matter if,
say, you're under the gun,
and you're in the low stack.
Can you do this?
WILL MA: Right.
So the stack size does matter.
So I'm assuming if everyone
had the same stack size
in that extreme
example, where I said
other people should
fold aces, I'm
assuming everyone has
the same stack size.
AUDIENCE: I guess where's the
balance between knocking you
out versus the
chips differential?
WILL MA: Right, exactly.
So the reason, in
that case where
it's correct to fold
aces, is because let's say
they call and knock me out.
It doesn't help them that
much because first place
in a satellite does not get
paid any more than 10th place.
But in real tournaments,
you basically
never fold aces
because even if you're
risking losing all your
money, just first place
will be hire than
second place by enough.
And winning with those aces
will increases your chances
of coming first by so much that
you should just gamble anyway.
So this is only in satellites.
Yeah, please don't fold aces in
like a normal poker tournament.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you're a short
stack in a satellite or one
of the shorter stacks, does
going all in still make sense?
Because people can call you
without risking a tournament.
WILL MA: Right, exactly.
So in that case, you actually
need a good had to go all in.
You actually need to
have positive chip EV
as well to go all in.
Yeah, so that's why when ICM is
relevant, the small stacks win.
And the big-- sorry,
the small stacks lose.
And the big stacks win.
Because the big stacks
have more license
to bully small sacks around,
whereas the small stacks can't
because the big stacks can
call at them more often.
AUDIENCE: And also does it
matter if other people have
raised behind you?
Does it just matter
who goes all in first?
WILL MA: So if someone's
already raised,
then it's more likely
you going all in--
it's more likely
they are already
committed so that if you
go all in, they won't fold.
So that is relevant, yeah.
OK, and cool.
Right, so exactly.
So in practice,
it's very tricky.
And in fact, it
can be beneficial
if you can somehow convince
your opponents that you're not
rational.
I've never personally
done this, but I've
heard of people making a bad
call sometimes in a satellite
just so people know not to
mess with him essentially.
But I mean it's a bit weird.
There is this weird
metagame with this traffic
intersection-type
game, although this
is only relevant in the most
extreme ICM situations, which
are satellites.
Actually, I should
say, one scenario
where I think you could
consider folding aces
preflop in a normal
tournament is actually this.
Let's say there's 55 until--
let's say 54 get paid.
And there's 55 left.
And you've got one
chip, and everyone else
has thousands of chips.
And you know that
someone else has already
gotten eliminated that hand.
So if you fold, you're
guaranteed to get in the money.
Then I would
definitely fold aces
because even if you win in
double up, congratulations,
you now have 10 chips
instead of one chip.
Everyone still has
thousands of chips.
There are cases where you could
construct an extreme case where
you should fold aces
preflop in a tournament,
in a normal tournament as well.
OK, so let's get back
to the tournament now.
OK, where were we?
So we lost a bunch
of chips here.
So the next hand we
get king-8 offsuit.
I raise from the button.
So we are committed here.
It sucks because our hand
sucks, but it's way too
good odds to call.
And ICM is nowhere
near that relevant
when it's against
the small stack.
It's the guy you're
trying to eliminate.
So we call.
We get pretty lucky here.
Good redemption for that
terrible jack-10 hand
played by me.
OK, so there's
three players left.
So ICM is still very relevant.
We're the second stack.
So we're trying not to get in
a big all-in with this guy,
although it's less significant
because this guy still
has a decent amount of chips.
If this guy only
had 50,000 chips,
then I would try a lot
harder to avoid getting
in a big pot with BeMySponsor.
So-- oops.
So yeah, so he raises,
and LPMBox goes all in,
takes it down.
So this hand, he makes it 3x.
And I decide to call it here
with queen-6 suited, which
is gutsy I think.
But I think it's in position,
and it's fairly deep.
And being able to put ICM
pressure on him is reasonable.
I think it could
have gone either way.
Folding is definitely
the safer play,
but queen-6 suited is
plenty good enough here.
So I call.
He just checks.
He might just be
giving up on this board
where there's a decent amount
of-- it's fairly dry, right?
So from what I said last class,
if the board is fairly dry,
where every hand has something,
if you've got absolutely
nothing, then
there's not even much
point to make a bluff like if
he's got ace-2 offsuit here.
So he just checks in,
and I bet, and he folds.
So he probably had ace-2
offsuit some hand like that.
Next hand we get ace-king.
I decide to raise
small here once again.
So I guess this protects
that jack-10 hand.
If I'm doing this
with jack-10, I
do need to do it with good
hands as well to protect
the times I do have jack-10.
Unfortunately, he
guesses correctly.
He doesn't fold, and I
have jack-10 and folds.
And I have ace-king.
So he still take that one downs.
And we win the blinds
the next hand again.
So suddenly we're worried
chip leader by a decent margin
after those three hands.
9-4 off-- I'm not going
to call, so fold to him.
So jack-7, so once
again, because of ICM,
this guy just goes all in
knowing we can't call that
much.
Takes it down.
7-6 offsuit, I decide to fold.
I think that's very reasonable
considering they can just
go all in on top of that.
Queen-9, queen-9
off, get a walk.
So one thing I
should pay attention
is I do think these guys--
by now I've collected
enough data points
of getting a walk way
more often than I should,
where I think it's not
just a coincidence.
I'm statistically confident
enough that they're actually
just giving me too many walks.
So when they don't
give me a walk,
I should put them on a
stronger range of hands
than I normally do.
Pocket 10s, we three-bet
this guy again.
He gets away again.
So 6-2 off, so we've
gotten dealt good cards
even though we haven't gotten
too much action from them.
We're still winning by two
chips from getting good cards.
So jack-4 off, I'm going
to fold to this guy.
So as you can see,
it's fairly boring,
but I think this
is what essentially
should happen in the
final couple of people
left in the tournament.
Ace-10 off, so I decide
to not go all in here.
I guess that would be 27 big--
26 and a 1/2 big blinds,
which is a bit much.
So I decided to
just raise small.
If he three-bets, if he
reraises to, say, 60,000,
I'm always going all in here.
If he goes all in himself,
I'm basically not folding
even though it sucks from
an ICM point of view.
I think ace-10 offsuit
is just way too good.
So I'm essentially just raising
small looking for action here.
He folds.
7-2 offsuit, we raise-- no.
[LAUGHTER]
So LPMBox gets a walk.
Queen-3 off, we get another
walk, which is nice.
Jack-5 off, I raise
here, which is definitely
an exploitative play.
It's definitely not-- definitely
from a Nash equilibrium optimal
play point of view,
there's no way
the optimal strategy is to
raise a fraction of hand
so big that it includes
jack-5 offsuit.
But I think at the
time, I probably
told myself, this guy
was being overly scared.
Even though he was playing
somewhat aggressive earlier on,
he is maybe
overadjusting for ICM
and is respecting me
too much in the presence
of this short stack.
I can look at the HUD
stats at the time,
although they won't be that
accurate because they're
going to include all the hands.
So normally I do play
with all these numbers on.
So we can see that his--
yeah, but it's
going to be biased
because this includes
the hands with six
or seven people at the table.
But it says that he calls
from the big blind only 20%
of the time.
But that's not a great--
yeah, that's going to biased.
So it doesn't tell us too much.
But I guess at the time,
I must have told myself
I'm going to try to
exploit this guy.
That's the only way I
can see why I decided
to raise jack-5 offsuit here.
So we get a call.
But I'm going to
continuation bet.
We do have a
backdoor heart draw,
and this is our best chance
of just winning the pot.
And I could maybe barrel on--
by barrel, I mean bet again as
a bluff on a bunch of turns.
So I just bet here.
He does fold.
Next hand with queen-9,
we open the button,
but we get shoved on.
And I guess we have to fold.
Queen-4, we get another walk.
Yes, so this is actually
getting ridiculous.
It seems like we've
literally gotten
five or six walks in a row.
And I would guess probably we
should be getting a walk less--
I guess at a three-handed
table, it's more often but still
less than like 30% of the time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it
possible you're getting
walks because someone
has raised your big blind
and you defended a lot?
And so they're scared
to raise your big blind?
WILL MA: Maybe.
I have been fairly active.
But I did fold a bunch of--
I did fold some borderline
situations, though,
like this jack--
I think it was a
different jack-7.
But yeah, maybe.
That's possibly.
Yeah, very good point.
But that's good, right?
It's good that we're like--
I'm not complaining that
we're getting a lot of stuff.
And we are the big stack, so in
general, it is harder for them
to bully us around than
us to bully them around.
So it does make sense from
that point of view, too.
I saw that it was just too many.
Anyway, so I just
continue trying
to raise a lot, especially
against this guy.
So jack-8 offsuit,
we take it down.
Jack-2, maybe we
could have folded.
But by now this guy was
getting short enough.
He's blinded down from
15 and 1/2 big blinds,
I think, to 13 and 1/2.
He might have had
more before, like 17.
So he might be looking
for a spot to shove now.
BeMySponsor actually
raises a small here
and gets him to fold.
And jack-6 off here.
We get another walk.
I should just skip the
hands on big blinds
since nothing ever happens,
which is great for us.
So pocket 3s here,
I just go all in.
So I talked about this before.
What's a problem with what
this play in some sense?
AUDIENCE: Reverse implied odds?
WILL MA: Right, good.
So yeah, so if I don't do
this, if I just raise small,
I have bad reverse
implied odds, right?
But one particular issue
is every other time
we've made it 25,000.
And really nothing's changed,
and suddenly we go all in.
So it is a bit suspicious
where he basically
knows we have a hand that has
very bad reverse implied odds.
He basically knows we have
pocket 3s or ace-4 offsuit
or something like that.
But it's still hard
for him to exploit.
I mean sure, you can call
ace-9 and exploit us,
but ace-9 is already
a great hand.
Or you can call pocket
4s and exploit us,
but it's not that easy to get
dealt pocket 4s or a better
pair than pocket 4s.
So here yeah, even though
against a good player, he knows
my range is a very small
specific number of hands.
It's still hard for him to--
he can't really just
call jack-10 suited here.
Maybe he can, but probably
jack-9 suited or queen-7
suited he can't call
because there's still
an off chance we have
queen-9 offsuit or something.
Oops.
So anyway, so he does fold.
But it definitely
raises suspicion.
Jack-10 off, so jack-10
off, we just go all in here.
So this is actually important.
So normally I would just
raise from the button,
but by now, the big
blind has gotten
so short that I'm
willing to just go
all in because the big blind is
short enough where even if he
picks up a hand and
calls and beats me,
I'm still the chip leader,
even if that happens.
So the ICM doesn't hurt
me that much because--
yeah, and also just the
fact that I'm risking less.
The other important thing of
the big blind getting short
is now the small blind is much
less incentivized to gamble
than before.
Before, when the
big blind had 180K,
he was incentivizing
gambling against me
because it's not that easy to
wait for the big blind to bust.
But now that the big
blind only has 10K,
it's easier to just wait
and hope that he busts.
So basically ICM becomes a lot
more favorable in both cases.
And shoving, I think, is very
good now with the stack sizes.
So we do shove, and
we take it down.
9-2 off, so no one
usually wants our blinds,
but then they both
want our blinds.
LPMBox takes it down.
So ace-2, I just go all in here.
Basically same justification
as the pocket 3s.
8-7 off, I think I probably
should have raised this.
Even going all in honestly
might not be that bad.
I'd have to do an
exact calculation,
but I think probably--
it's a pretty bad hand.
But I think probably I
shouldn't be folding given
that I'm the big stack and
given that they've both
been giving me lots of respect.
But I fold, which
can be a big mistake.
But I think probably I
shouldn't have folded.
The next hand, LPMBox
goes all in, and we fold.
Next hand, we 8-7
suited, so by now,
this guy, BeMySponsor,
so we've just won enough
pots where this guy
is also short now.
So it's a pretty good situation
for us from an ICM perspective.
They're both short enough where
we can just go all in preflop
very often and they have
to fold quite often.
10-7 off is a bit too weak,
but I decide to raise.
But yeah, this is a bit
inconsistent play from my part
because I think
for most purposes,
8-7 off is a better
hand than 10-7 off.
But for some reason I raise
10-7 off and fold 8-7 off.
He's 5-suited.
We get a walk again.
Queen-5 off, yeah, so
I just go all in here.
So this is definitely not
a plus chip EV all-in,
but once again I
think ICM by now
is relevant enough where
it's fine because he just
has to fold, weakening it down.
10-6 off, I decide to fold.
Big blind gets a walk.
Get a walk with
6-deuce pretty good.
Ace-2 off, once
again, we go all in.
They fold.
Pocket kings, so I basically--
AUDIENCE: Wow.
WILL MA: Yeah, so this is
a bit suspicious again.
Normally I've been going all in.
He raises small.
Obviously yes, pocket kings.
So yeah, that's basically true.
But I mean also I
think I will do this
with some of the
weakest hands that I'm
not willing to
gamble all in with
but still want to raise maybe
something like 9-7 offsuit
maybe.
But we don't play it,
so we take it down.
So he goes all in.
We fold jack-2 offsuit.
Queen-3 suited, go all in.
So I'm going to go
through this fairly fast.
There's a lot of same stuff.
6-5 off, we fold because
yeah, by now they're
short enough where they
might actually just call us
pretty often.
So I fold 6-5 off.
So here, pocket 3s holds
against queen-jack.
So this is an extreme ICM spot.
So he calls here, and
he does double up.
So the next hand, we do
have an extreme ICM spot
because this guy only
has one big blind.
So essentially their
correct strategy
is going to be I'm supposed
to shove any two cards.
And he's only supposed
to call, I would guess,
maybe the top 7% or 8%
of hands in a situation.
He normally should be
calling top 30 or something.
So I just go all in.
Even if he has ace-2 offsuit,
I'm certain he has to fold.
Even if he has, say, king-queen,
and I turn up my hand
and show him jack-8,
he probably still
has to fold just because
he really can't bust.
I haven't done the
exact math, but I
wouldn't be that
surprised if he told me
pocket 9s is a fold for him.
I wouldn't be that
surprised, so yeah.
So once again, I go all in
because this guy probably
can't call.
Oh, OK, so yeah.
We win against
ace-queen, which is crazy
that they picked up ace-queen
with one big blind, right?
Anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
Some players like to do this
thing called cooperative play
to get that big blind to bust.
In the history of
poker, it's what
was almost customary for the
players who have chips in here
to basically just all agree
to just call and not raise
each other and to maximize
their chances of busting
the big blind.
It's a form of
cheating in some sense.
It's collusion in some sense.
But it's customary maybe
five-six years ago for everyone
to do this because it
benefits everyone else.
It benefits all of these guys
if they all agree to do this.
And it just
maximizes the chances
that the big blind
is eliminated.
But the issue with
this is unfortunately
there is an option
to be selfish.
Unfortunately, if we both
trusted each other completely,
we could collude and be like,
OK, we're just going to call,
check down every flop
turn and river no matter
what to match so that we can
both see the river with any two
cards and maximize the
chances of busting this guy.
The issue with this is when you
play a game, you're selfish.
If there is an
opportunity to bet
because you have a good hand,
you're going to want to bet.
If there's a draw and
you have a good hand,
you want to bet to get
the other guy to fold.
And basically from a game
theoretic perspective,
since we have these
options, there's
no way for us to
essentially agree
that we're going to just check
down and see the river, which
is why I consider collusion
of players actually do this.
So nonetheless, I do
the most selfish line,
which is just go all in.
But yeah, if this guy
was my best friend
and I wanted to cheat, then
I could just call and let
him call and then
just check it down
even if I flopped the nut flush.
OK, so now it's heads up.
OK, I'll try to show every hand.
OK, so now ICM doesn't matter.
But it would be good to
show a little heads up play
because I don't think
we've done too much
heads up play in this class.
So we call here.
And we check.
He makes it 32.
And I just have to
check-raise bluff this flop.
I think it's close.
I think I probably
shouldn't be folding.
I think jack-6 suited
just has too many backdoor
draws on this flop to ever fold
just as part of my strategy.
I think I decided that I
wanted my strategy to be I'm
going to raise good
hands, like 8s and 4s.
And then I'm going to also raise
hands with lots of backdoor
draws like jack-6 of hearts.
So I decide to do this.
So unfortunately he
goes all in, so we fold.
It doesn't quite work.
So queen-10 off, we raise.
Oh, so one thing
I should say is--
I think most of you know
this-- but once a tournament
gets heads up and it's just a
small blind and the big blind,
the small blind is
actually has position.
So normally when it's small
blind against big blind,
the bid blind has
position postflop.
But when it's heads
up as a small blind,
you actually have position.
So you're very strongly
incentivized to play
from this small blind.
It's just by far
the better position
because you have
position, and you
have to put in less of a blind.
So another cheat that--
so I'm teaching you guys
all these different cheats.
Another cheat that
people used to do--
it's not really a cheat.
But another angle shoot people
used to do back in the day is
there would be people who
normally play pretty low
stakes, let's say, $0.25, $0.50.
They would set up
these $25, $50 tables.
So where the blinds
are $25, $50, which
is really high stakes for them.
They really don't have the
bankroll to gamble that.
But their strategy
basically is if you're
the first to sit
down, you get to be
the dealer on the first hand.
So their strategy
is basically just
sit there and then wait for
someone else to sit down.
And then play the first
hand as the dealer, where
they have a huge advantage.
They can just raise, and
usually the other guy will fold,
and they'll win 50 bucks,
which is a huge deal to them.
And then they'll just
leave after the first hand.
So this is something that
happened quite a lot.
So my friends and
I, we've talked
about playing a
crazy strategy, where
you would sit down knowing this
is what the other guy's going
to do.
And then sit down with him.
We would have the
capital to take on risk.
And then we would basically
just play the first hand
extremely aggressively.
And knowing that the guy has
been fold most of the time,
because if he calls, that's
all his money on the site.
So yeah, it led to a
lot of weird dynamics.
But OK, so here we have--
This is why I chose
tournaments, not cash games.
There's fewer ways to do
these when you use cheats.
So queen-10, we raise.
We take it down.
Next hand we get
ace-queen suited.
So unfortunately we get a walk.
So queen-8, we raise.
We take it down--
sorry, he calls.
And then it's checked to us.
We continuation bet.
And he raises, which
is weird because it's
a flop that's a lot better
for my range than his
because I can have
ace-king and ace-queen.
And even ace-jack, I
think, if he had ace-jack,
he would have reraised preflop.
So in some sense it's
weird because it's
really hard for him
to have, I think,
pocket aces or pocket 8s.
Or even pocket 3s,
he probably would
have reraised all on preflop.
So really it's like,
what do you have?
It's like, I don't have much.
But really it's like,
what do you have?
So it's weird because I expect
him to check-raise this flop so
rarely that what he does, on
the one hand, it's just strange.
But on the other hand,
he must know that.
I'm assuming it's
somewhat balanced,
and he will occasionally turn
up ace-3 or something here.
So I decide to call
and see one more card.
I don't know if that's great.
Maybe I should have just
folded and just believed him
or just reraised if
I didn't believe him.
Reraise essentially is a bluff.
Make it 100,000, and
just hope he folds.
But I decide to call.
The turn is a 9 putting
out some straight draws
but no flush draws.
That's fairly big, and I fold.
I don't really know how I feel
about how I played that hand.
I think I mostly
played exploitatively.
I just called the flop because
I wanted to see what he did,
and I folded the
turn because maybe
based on his bet sizing
or his bet timing,
I just felt like he had it.
So I'm not sure I'm
extremely happy with how
I played that hand.
But probably just at
the time, I decided
to play exploitatively and
try to play best against how
I expect him to act.
So here 10-7 off, I
decide to reraise.
So the reason I reraise a
hand as bad as 10-7 offsuit--
I talked a bit about this two
classes ago about your preflop
raising strategy.
So essentially
what I'm doing is I
want to be reraising
my good hands
and also my hands that I'm
not sad if he goes all in,
and I have to fold, and I
don't get to see a flop with.
So if I had 10-7 suited,
that's too good of a hand.
And I really don't
want to reraise.
And then if he goes all in,
fold my pretty 10-7 suited
and not even get to
see a flop with it.
But 10-7 offsuit is
a bad enough hand
where I'm not that sad
if he just goes all in,
and I have to fold.
So that's why I'm
raising my good hands
and also my weakest
possible hands
that I'm OK if I don't
get to see a flop with.
He does call unfortunately,
but we do hit a great flop.
So I'm just going to
bet and get it all in.
Heads up basically any
top pair is, in general,
just way more good enough to
put all your money in with.
He folds, though.
So ace-6, we raise.
I'm going to go fairly
quickly because I'm
running a bit short of time.
We continuation bet the
flop and take it down.
He raises here.
I call with king-6, which
is pretty borderline.
It's too good a hand to
fold, but probably it's
too bad a hand to call.
Probably I should
have just raised
by the same logic as before.
But we call.
And I decide to donk
out on this flop
because I figured there's a
number of draws I can have.
And here I do have a weak draw.
A 7 gives me a bad
streak but still
a very good hand in
the two-player pot.
He calls.
And the turn is a
jack, which I still
have a straight draw because
now a queen gives me a straight.
So I continue bluffing.
So he folds, which is good.
6-2 offsuit I just
give one to them.
So yeah, I think you
should be playing
90-95% percent of buttons.
Maybe not that high when
it's getting shallower,
but at least 80% of buttons.
But 2-3 offsuit is one of the
hands I'm OK with folding.
8-5 suited, I'm just
check-raising this flopping,
getting it in.
He folds-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Let's say
you had an opponent
that from the big blind was
very likely to three-bet you.
How would you adjust
your range opening
from the button or
the small blind?
WILL MA: Oh, OK.
So if they're really
loose, you would basically
raise only your good
hands that you're hoping
they reraise all in with.
And--
AUDIENCE: So would that be
from maybe 60% of your hands
down from 80?
WILL MA: Oh, yeah.
You would basically raise less.
So it'd just have more
value essentially.
AUDIENCE: It's hard to
calibrate that range, though,
as what's a good hand.
WILL MA: Yeah, and also another
thing you can do is call more.
I don't think it gets relevant
in this heads up match.
But sometimes it
gets shallow enough
where you actually want
to have a calling range
preflop from the button.
OK, so king-10.
OK, so I do call here.
I think I essentially
call, thinking
I would call if he went
all in but also just
to make it so that I
can also sometimes call
a hand like 10-4 offsuit.
And he can't just shove any
2 and expect me to fold.
So I decide to call here.
We get a great flop, so I
check it back as a slow play.
He checks again on the turn.
So I bet.
He calls.
The river he leads
out quite big.
And I just call because I
think raising I'll usually only
get called by better.
And he actually turns
up a flush here.
So it's a weird hand.
It seems like we could
have lost a lot more.
But I'm not saying our
opponent played the hand badly,
but we were very lucky to
lose this little when we have
a two pair against a flush.
And we only lost, essentially,
four big blinds or something.
I guess I'll be happy
to get away with that.
OK, I'll probably run two
or three minutes over time.
I'll try to hurry.
But I don't want to not
finish the tournament today.
So we fooled this.
Maybe I'll skip forward a bit
to some of the bigger pots.
So what happened here?
So we raise jack-6.
He goes all in.
We fold.
All right, let's go do this one.
OK, so king-- so OK, so the
match has gone on for a bit.
He's won a bunch of pots.
He catching up.
He's catching up.
King-3 off, we raise.
He calls.
So here the flop I
think is-- so once again
it's a situation where I don't
think he ever has an ace.
So I'm basically
betting at 100%.
He calls.
The turn's another ace,
which is a bad card for us
because now it's less
likely we have an ace.
But normally, I still
think it's a fine spot
to bluff just because he
essentially can't have an ace
and we can.
But I think king-high is
good enough here where
I am going to win the pot by
checking it down with king-high
often enough that
bluffing is superfluous.
So I just check.
And it's checked down.
And he was actually
trapping with king-9 here.
So he wins that one.
Yeah, and probably he
wouldn't have folded.
Let's say, I bet the turn
and went all in on the river.
Probably he has to call just
because it's almost the best
hand he can possibly have.
It pretty much is the
best hand you can possibly
have other than maybe 7-6.
I think nothing happens there.
So let me see.
OK, so yeah, we lose a bunch
of pots because we raise
and he reraises and we fold.
So things aren't
looking too good.
Oh, so I actually
made a hero fold here.
I think, once again, this
is an exploitative play.
I would probably never fold
this from an optimal strategy
point of view.
I think an ace in heads
up with only 20 big blinds
is way too good.
But he did just reraise
me two hands ago.
And I don't know.
I think at the time I just felt
like he almost certainly had it
when he did this.
I made an exploitative fold
based on what I thought he had.
So the next hand, he raises.
We go all in with pocket 5s.
And we've never
[INAUDIBLE] the ace-jack
which is pretty stupid.
Yeah, I was very surprised.
I was basically
ready to just leave.
I was probably in some
other tournaments.
But I basically was
ready to close the table
and focus on the
other tournaments.
But somehow we get there.
And then the tournament
just is easy from there.
We get ace-9.
We go all in.
He folds.
And then he goes all
in into our pocket 6s.
And we hit a
straight, so we win.
Right,
So I played through all
the hands at a tournament.
Once again, there's a lot
of selection bias there.
But hopefully you learned
some stuff from that.
So there's two classes left.
Next class, I'll wrap up the
theory and the exact poker
example.
So I'll talk a bit
more about cash games
and show you how to play
when you're really deep.
I talked about postflop raising.
And then Friday we
have a guest lecture
from Bill Chen, which
should be really exciting.
He always talks about
very interesting stuff.
So I'll see you guys around.